قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تواصل ما سمته عملياتها الدفاعيه
في مقاطعتي خرسون وزابالوجيا الجنوبيه
البلاد واضافت الهيئه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه
على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه واعتادها
ومنظوماتها الصاروخيه اشارت الان المدفعيه
استهدفت امس ثلاثه مخازن للذخيره والاسلحه
ومجمعا لمنظومه صواريخ اس 3
نقاط تحكم
ضمرون من
الصمادي وارصد معك اخر التطورات حيث انت
وتدافع تتابع الدمار الذي يظهر في الخلفيه
تامر
صباح الخير محمد في البدايه الهجوم كان
واسعا على العاصمه كياب وعديده المقاطعات
الجنوبيه الحديث هنا
عنبروجيا وفقا لقياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه في كييف تحدثت عمده العاصمه عن
اسقاط الدفاعات الاوكرانيه ما يقرب من
اربعين مسيره هجوميه من نوع شاهد وقال بان
حطام تلك المسيرات ادى الى بعض الاضرار في
مواقع مختلفه من العاصمه لكن في الحقيقه
المسيرات تكثفت المسيرات الهجوميه بطبيعه
الحال والصواريخ ايضا من نوع كروز تكتفت
على المقاطعات
الجنوبيه قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تحدث عن اسقاط الدفاعات الاوكرانيه 37
صاروخا
من نوع كروز اطلقت منه بحر قزوين وتحدث
ايضا عن اسقاط 29 مسيره هجوميه القياده
الجنوبيه لاسيما المتحدثه باسمها العقيد
نتالياه قالت بان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
اسقطت عددا من المسيرات في اوديسا وقالت
بان حطام احدى المسيرات الحق اضرارا
بالبنيه التحتيه في ميناء اوديسا ولم تقدم
مزيدا من التفاصيل لكنها ايضا تحدثت عن
اسقاط بعض تلك المسيرات في عموم الاتجاهات
الجنوبيه هنا في ميكولا تحدثت عمده
المدينه عن اسقاط ثلاثه منها واكد استمرار
القصف المدفعي الثقيل للقوات الروسيه على
طول المناطق الساحليه وتحدث عن اضرار
كبيره في الحقيقه لا سيما في مناطق
اوتشاكوف وكوستروب وفي خرسون ايضا تواصل
القصف الروسي بالمدفعيه الثقيله على قلب
المدينه وعلى العديد من القرى على خط
التماس عمده المقاطعه الاوكراني تحدث عن
عشرات الهجمات خلال الساعات الماضيه وقال
بان الفرق المتخصصه اضطرت الى اجلاء عشرات
المدنيين من المناطق الاكثر تضررا للقصف
وتم نقلهم الى اماكن اكثر امنا كما قال
والقصف المتبادل ايضا تواصل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول خط
المواجهه في ضفتي عند ضفتي نهر دينيبر
والحديث وفقا للقياده الجنوبيه عن خسائر
كبيره تكبدتها القوات الروسيه في الارواح
والعتاد والحديث ايضا عن اكثر من سريه تم
قتلها وجرحها للقوات الروسيه وفقا للمتحدث
باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في خرسون
وزاباروجيا في زبروجيا ايضا تواصل القصف
على المناطق الماهوله بالسكان من قبل
القوات الروسيه وفقا للاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وفي المقابل كثافه القوات
الاوكرانيه من قصفها
الجنوبي الحديث عن توك ماك وميلي توبيل
على وجه التحديد التي تتواجد فيها القوات
الروسيه وفي الجبهات الشرقيه ايضا تحدثت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن محاولات
مستمره للقوات الروسيه بالسيطره على
منطقتي لوغان سكواك وتحدثت عن اتجاهات
الجبهه المختلفه لاسيما باخموت وابديافكا
ومارينكا واليمان وقالت بان القوات
الروسيه
صدت هجوما متكررا وصفته بالفاشل للقوات
الروسيه على محوري مارينكا وباخ موت وقالت
بان القوات ايضا الاوكرانيه مازالت تكتف
من ضربها للمواقع الروسيه في تلك
الاتجاهات
شكرا جزيلا لك من